on a rarement l'occasion de voir arabes
se créer des marques d'arrivée tout au
début et pouvoir voir les premiers pas
de la marque ses premiers essais ses
premiers produits c'est ce qui nous
arrive aujourd'hui avec nothing nothing
sort le premier produit qui s'appelle
les ikhwan
des écouteurs alors on pourrait se dire
tiens il ya beaucoup de haye pour une
tour des écouteurs mais surtout la
marque qui est intéressante c'est
l'histoire de la marque d'où vient la
marque qui est derrière la marque
comment tu vas à keith ça va très bien
et
ouais écoute ça va très heureux je suis
content de pouvoir te parler sur sur ce
nouveau projet de vaud avait no 6 a fait
un petit moment qu'on a discuté tous les
deux je voudrais que tu me parles de la
marque au tout début quand voilà en
discuter par rapport à ce nouveau projet
ce qu'on voulait faire et c'est là il y
avait deux axes qu'on voulait vraiment
adressé un c'était l'aspect éco système
donc tu vois travailler sur une gamme de
produits ou au final tous les produits
vont être
interconnectés entre eux et créer un
petit peu cet écosystème de produits qui
réfléchit au final de a à z et qui d'un
point de vue expérience ultra fluide un
produit un autre et donc ça ça va se
faire de manière graduelle ou fort à
mesure et au fur et à mesure des années
dont va entre clans de plus en plus dans
plusieurs catégories de produits et
après le deuxième point c'était
également ça se fait un petit peu de
design donc on voulait vraiment finale
avec nothing voir si on pouvait créer
une vraie identité visuelle on est parti
sur ce domaine en cheveux de
transparence et produit un toit dans
l'industrie tassé confusion il ya
différentes gammes de produits
différents noms et tout devient un petit
peu plus compliqué donc à nous on
voulait vraiment cette fois ci on
simplifier la chose bien évidemment on
va sur de l'anglais parce que notamment
la boîte et etc c'est une boîte anglaise
mai mai du contrat notre approche sur
toutes les les différents noms c'est
vraiment de garder un truc simple et
d'un point de vue et expériences d'avoir
un truc assez simplifier on veut pas
aller les chercher à faire des sous les
avants différentes applications et c'est
donc vraiment qui centralise et d'un
point de vue l'expérience utilisateur
sur mesure on pense que cet écosystème
ils nous ont fait un pas quasi qui est
super sympa pour l'ouvrir regarder on
loue comme une languette de flamby on
prend alors pendant des moules mais en
tout cas on nous alors ce qui est un peu
con c'est qu'une fois que vous l'avez
ouvert et bien vous l'avez endommagés
donc vous n'avez plus accès à ce joli
packaging donc c'est un côté un peu
éphémère pourquoi pas ça peut être aussi
un peu expérientiel mais par contre il
ya un côté très satisfaisant à l'ouvrir
comme ça à regarder leur sort bon là
c'est tout de suite un peu plus
classique l'a65 vraiment dur elle
j'aurais aimé retrouver sensiblement la
même chose ici est ce que pour des
questions qui n'ont pas fait je sais pas
après je viens ouvrir et voilà la bête
[Musique]
m
une toute petite languette pour y
retirer et me faire venir pour venir les
appéré je prends j'ouvre c'est hyper
simple ça doit venir se connecter
directement nothing ikhwan sera associée
à votre compte se connecter votre
appareil et près de configurer vous avez
les petits en bouffe il ya trois tailles
différentes vous avez ici petites
informations sur le produit c'est
vachement bien moi j'adore la typo
qu'ils ont choisi j'adore l'univers vous
explique comment ça marche le fasse père
le fasse peur c'est uniquement sur
android après l'application pour
l'utiliser sur android mais également
sur ios donc ça ça marche très très bien
et là vous avez un câble en usb c'est
pour venir les charges et même le canal
des saintes 1 ont fait un truc qui est
très cool comme ça c'est pas mal du tout
donc usb sbc et sinon vous téléchargez
directement son fils aussi voulait poser
comme ça que ça marche bien ici on nous
annonce une autonomie de trente quatre
heures ça va dépendre bien évidemment si
vous avez activé la réduction de bruit
ou pas et pour en revenir à l'aspect
transparence était assez complexe au
final parce que toutes les différentes
détail en fait font maintenant partie de
manière intégrale du design et du coup
il va il a fallu deux tours au travail
donc c'est à dire des aimants par
exemple les éléments de base à c'était
assez dur de trouver un partenaire parce
que il n'y avait aucun nos partenaires
qui voulaient travailler dans ce niveau
détail où aller il fallait vraiment
retravailler les est membre par exemple
le léman sur le haut qui est vraiment
pas parlé depuis - ça sent réside sur
différents produits mais vraiment duo
way a donc c'était hyper compliqué
d'avoir quelque chose de symétrie
quelque chose de poly et encore une fois
trouvé le partenaire qui avait travaillé
dans ce niveau des détails donc ça ça
nous a pris pas mal de temps après les
micros également la réduction de bruit
actif micro de base ils sont moches il
faut dire ce qui est a donc il a fallu
retravailler les griefs est un niveau en
fait de détail qui qui entrent en jeu et
pour lequel on n'avait pas forcément
prévu un hills a été chaque détail enfin
que ça soit la plus autour des électeurs
et la partie du riz du pain a donc tout
ça ça a été des détails qu'il a fallu
résoudre des problèmes qui sont venues
se rajouter qu'il faut résoudre
cela vous coûter une fortune à fabriquer
un produit comme ça du coup la
conception résoudre tous ces problèmes
parce que c'est quoi ce 99 euros la
paire d'écouteurs 4 c'est pas très cher
par rapport à tout ce que vous avez fait
derrière en r&d sur un premier produit
sur un lancement de marques c'est pas
très cher on aurait pu peut-être prendre
un petit peu plus cher ce qui est très
cool avec ce produit c'est effectivement
un vrai parti pris qui est complètement
différent mais ce qui est également
intéressant c'est ce qu'on va retrouver
à l'intérieur à l'intérieur on a un
driver de 11,6 mm ce qui est intéressant
est ce que j'aime beaucoup moi c'est
vraiment la tenue c'est vraiment un
produit qui est tout riquiqui vous
prenez vous le posez vous le tournez
appel il se positionne directement aix
positionne très très facilement donc on
a une très très très bonne tenue alors
là vous avez de la réduction de bruit
passive la réduction brute passif c'est
quoi c'est que ça vient boucher les
oreilles que vous avez la réduction de
bruit active qui va venir à nu les
leçons extérieur grâce à plusieurs
micros et puis vous avez ce qu'ils
appellent le mode transparence qui
permet de venir capté au travers de
trois micros tout ce qu'il ya dans votre
pièce pour venir nous restituer augmenté
dans les oreilles
ce mode transparence est pas mal ce plat
le plus fou que j'ai pu entendre avant
de vous parler de la qualité audio je
vous faire un petit point sur
l'expérience globale en appel
téléphonique bah oui parce que ce sont
des écouteurs on peut aussi passer des
coups de fil avec sa marche verte
franchement ça se complique très
rapidement c'est hyper sable j'ai
absolument aucun problème et s'il ya du
bluetooth 5.2 la qualité audio est bonne
le seul truc que je veux dire un petit
peu reproché lors des appels c'est que
la réduction passive pour le coup marche
un peu trop bien et j entends pas trop
ma voix alors l'idée c'est pas de
rentrer en deux mois par année quand je
parle à quelqu'un mais c'est quand même
bien de pouvoir s'entendre un petit peu
donc il faudrait un peu plus de votre
transparence pour réussir à mieux
s'entendre mais malgré tout ça fait très
très bien le boulot est l'intérêt
d'avoir cette réduction passive qui
marche bien alors vos appels
téléphoniques c'est que lorsque vous
passez un coup de fil dans un lieu qui
est un peu bruyant et bien ça vous isole
quand même pas mal alors après l'autre
paquet super intéressant aussi c'est la
qualité audio on se dit qu'on a
effectivement des écouteurs le but
d'écouter de la musique ouais ça c'est
clair on est à 99 euros à 99 euros
clairement ce ne sont pas les meilleurs
d'écouteurs qu'on peut retrouver sur le
marché mais malgré tout le boulot qu'ils
font ils le font vraiment bien alors
vous avez deux écoutes différentes
réductions brouille active désactiver
réduction brouille hâtive activée c'est
un petit peu différent lorsque vous
l'activez vous avez de l'électronique ça
vient manger quelques fréquences pour
pitre et de la meilleure expérience
sonore lorsque vous désactivez la
réduction de bruit c'est pas ici qu'on
va avoir le son le plus rond c'est pas
ici qu'on va voir les aigus les plus
précis mais malgré tout ça marche bien
vous avez une application qui vous
permet de venir moduler les coalisés
heures l'application les hyper simple
vous avez votre niveau de batterie le
nom des produits donc là aux attendes
réduction collective
au bassin votre transparents là vous
l'éteignez vous êtes d'ailleurs de
niveau 1 soit maximum soit light vu que
la réduction de bruit et pas non plus
hyper hyper parfaite mieux vaut se
mettre un maximum et vous avez en
dessous un équaliseur alors l'écho l'isr
est pas fou fou c'est pas un multi
bandes ou choisissez soit un peu en mode
automatique balz c'est ce que j'ai mis
un mort triebel le fonds devait pas
beaucoup plus et but et c'est moins
terrible cépage est mort basse bon vin
comme son nom l indique ça vous laisse
plus de basses est mort voice ça vous
monte aussi les médiums donc en fait
vous avez choix avec plus de médium plus
de graver plus d'aigus très clairement
ces trois modes là sont pas géniaux et
pour écouter de la musique c'est pas
dingue donc vous restez un mode band ça
ira parfaitement bien et on suit vous
pouvez venir régler le pavé tactile vous
appuyez sur touch sur l'écouteur gauche
en triple table ça va être chanson
suivante je peux voir chanson suivante
sur son précédent taux alors carrément
pas d'action voulait s'est appuyé sur
l'écouteur gauche et bien vous avez la
réduction bruit ou alors carrément pas
grand chose si vous faites la même chose
sur l'écouteur droit alors ce que
j'aurais aimé ses pouvoirs d'autres
actions j'ai le choix entre soit activé
la réduction de bruit soit rien du tout
j'imagine que l'application pourra être
amené à évoluer dans les temps à venir
c'est déjà bien qu'elle existe que vous
ayez ses options même si elles sont très
minimaliste et si clairement le vrai
intérêt de l'application est bien c'est
de pouvoir choisir un morceau suivant
morceau précédent à droite ou à gauche
et pouvoir venir activer désactiver ou
mettre le mode transparent au niveau de
la réduction bruit mais c'est tout parce
que les équaliseur franchement ça sert
pas à grand chose sur le haut vous avez
un petit menu qui vous dira qu'ils sont
les ikhwan vous avez un dark thème les
notifications la détection lorsque vous
les mettez dans les oreilles venir les
retrouver vous mettez lecture salissez
queen et je peux vous dire que vous
savez tout de suite où elles sont de
façon un peu global je trouve que le son
est quand même assez précis sur les
différentes bandes de fréquences on a
l'expérience qui est bonne sondés et
coûtera 99 euros une fois de plus il
faut vraiment envie d'aller re
positionner par rapport à leurs tarifs
on a des bases présentes mais pas trop
des médiums et des aigus qui sont assez
précis on pourrait avoir un peu plus de
précisions lorsqu'on monte en fréquence
vraiment au niveau des aigus mon père a
légèrement dans l'ensemble c'est pas
très grave et une fois de plus 99 euros
je puis vous assurer que ça fait le
boulot l'autre gros point fort ces
écouteurs c'est la réduction bruit
réduction bruit active forcément on veut
se coupe un petit peu de monde extérieur
alors une fois de plus 99 euros ça
fonctionne pas mal mais c'est pas la
meilleure a dit que son book j'ai pu
entendre une fois de plus 99 euros je
vais en avoir marre je suis vraiment en
boucle là dessus c'est vrai parce qu'en
fait ça laisse quand même passé pas mal
de choses gelée notamment essayée dans
le train qui est un endroit très
brouillon on entend quand même un petit
peu ce qui se passe je suis qu'à ce que
je lai bien mise j'ai fait le tour au
niveau de mon application oui si j'avais
bien mise clairement donc avait
effectivement cette traduction brouille
active mais pour autant jean grenet
quand même ce qui se passait alors sa
double filtre un peu ça vient diminuer
un petit peu les niveaux mais malgré
tout il ya des choses qui passent alors
point positif c'est que la réduction de
bruit passive est quand même pas mal et
vous bouche un peu les oreilles la
réduction proactive rajoute une couche
mais ce n'est pas le boulot à 100% le
truc qui peut peut-être faire un petit
peu râler c'est aussi au niveau des
codecs sbc a assez c'est tout on n'a
rien d'autre pas d'app été exploités x
hd pas de hell d'ac on a vraiment la
base de la base de la base de la base
truc est aussi très très cool et si
c'est qu'on a des écouteurs qui sont
résistant aux éclaboussures alors l'idée
c'est effectivement pas le jeter dans la
fosse parce que ça n'aurait strictement
aucun intérêt vous n'allez pas non plus
venir nager dans la piscine et puis vous
baigner avec et écouter de la musique
n'ont pas d'intérêt que c'est pas ça le
but le but c'est si vous transpirez et
vous faites du sport et bien vous êtes
pena ce qui est très bien lors de l'
usage sport c'est qu'on a une très très
bonne tenue alors il ya les écouteurs
qui sont vraiment faits pour le sport
mais là pour que vous pouvez en faire
vous pouvez aller courir faire du vélo
sans problème la tenue est très bonne
ils sont certifiés justement résistants
la transpiration et si vous sortez vous
écoutez de la musique et qui se met à
pleuvoir ça ira aussi est allé assez
assez assez assez vite faut dire parce
que au final la boîte elle a même pas un
an commencent à échanger un petit peu
sur sur l'idée hassani un petit peu sur
la vision de la marque
courant novembre l'année dernière assez
rapidement il ya du footing et de marque
niche un petit peu de base mais pour les
audiophiles assez connu et notamment
enfin pour leur design parce que j'ai
jamais travaillé avec des gens aussi
talentueux en termes de design a
toujours été vraiment impressionnée donc
le design bien notamment en travaillant
les queues qui sauve qui font partie de
l'équipe fondatrice de nothing donc on
on a eu des discussions avec eux assez
rapidement on a eu tout concept point
assez rapidement on a eu les premiers
croquis de diwan et à partir de là bas
on a fait un petit peu comme chaque
starter d'un dec gonds présent de
défense d'investisseurs
via notamment capté qui a
ainsi connu dans l'industrie qui est un
bon réseau on a commencé à parler avec
des gens comme kiss in est stable par
exemple et qui ont vite adhéré en fait à
la vision qu'ils ont qui pour eux il y
avait les mêmes opportunités
en terme de créer un écosystème ultra
cohérent de a à z et notamment d'un
point de vue design façon assez monotone
de manière générale il y avait la place
de faire quelque chose un petit peu
différent donc on a eu rapidement des
investisseurs
ndjambé sur
mon appel sont rattachés au projet suite
à ça un mois plus tard donc on avait
annoncé ans mi novembre du conseil le
premier lever 2,7 millions avec
notamment via les questionner stade
kevin vit l'un des cofondateurs de de
twitch y avait six of man 2 le sied aux
et fondateur de brigitte et on a finit
même par tony fadell qui est un des qui
était quelqu'un de très proche de steve
jobs c'est son équipe hier vers mantes
et l'ipod donc c'était quand même un
beau départ sur les chapeaux de roue et
au final après un mois plus tard robben
venture s'est rajoutée au projet dont
qui ont investi 15 millions
et et au final tout est allé assez vite
donc on va commencer vraiment
assez rapidement développement du
produit même avant la fin de
2020 et il voit là qu'on essaye t 15,7
points intense en termes de
développement de produits sains en même
temps parallèle monter toutes les
équipes parce qu'on a recruté manière si
agressif donc là on est plus en 1 depuis
quelques semaines on a des capacités de
production qui malheureusement sont pas
au niveau de la demande donc on essaie
de remédier à ça rapidement donc
j'espère que l'on va pouvoir rattraper
un peu le retard assez rapidement et je
sais qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui
attendent leurs héros et on se dit
qu'une marque qui arrivent et qui
commence avec des écouteurs vous venez
pas que pour des écouteurs c'est quoi la
suite de l'histoire on peut en parler ou
pas une des raisons qu'une enseigne
faisait c'était aussi voilà cette idée
est ce qu'on est ce qu'on peut créer
vraiment cet écosystème de produits
ultra connectés et avec une expérience
utilisateur qu'il peut bien hyper fluide
au point où la technologie est présente
et facilite
plein de choses dans ma vie mais forte
sans forcément être visible donc pour le
nom nothing donc ça va être ça sert type
à petit en sachant qu'ils voient les
équipes notamment certaines produits
catégories de produits qui sont plus
complexes d'autres à il va falloir
qu'ils les équipes derrière donc ça va
être de manière graduelle voilà on peut
pas non plus être mille personnes en
seulement quelques mois donc ça va se
faire petit à petit
quelles sont les catégories de produits
vous irez pas parce que tu vas quand tu
ne parles d'écosystèmes je pense à un
écosystème cap un exemple t'as apple
avec des tablettes des ordinateurs des
téléphones pas samsung qui va avec des
réfrigérateurs avec des lave-linge
connectés c'est quoi la limite que vous
est fixé ce qui est limite mais cela n'a
pas du tout ya une limite et qui un
comptable un écosystème après un
écosystème d'encensoir joueront des
micro-ondes des trottinettes et ses
enfants l'idée c'est d'avoir une
expérience utilisateur qui cohérente à
travers toutes les produits voient tous
les différents produits donc par exemple
voilà je me vois pas ou tout du moins
après voici à une vraie
idée en termes d'innovation sur comment
intégrer par exemple un micro dans cet
écosystème et éventuellement mais je ne
vois pas sortir
tout du moins dans cette courbe pour
iter sortir un micro-ondes par exemple
s'est pas lassé par des scores dit avoir
une certaine cohérence de différentes
autrui et être sûr qu'il va y avoir un
certain niveau d'intégration en un point
de vue expériences et puis je tiens à te
souhaiter bon courage parce que à
l'heure où à laquelle on tourne t pas
papa mais ça va pas tarder donc
félicitations en avance et puis bon
courage parce que les nuits vont être
blanchet et ça va être dur plus dur à
mon avis quand on tape ou tout de suite
et il ya beaucoup de travail
cool
je souhaite merci à qui ça bientôt
c'est l'heure de vous donner mon verdict
global s'est produit ikhwan de note nick
je les aime bien je les aime bien déjà
parce qu'ils ont un design est vraiment
différent est vraiment différenciant il
eu un super boulot qui a été fait au
niveau de l'esthétique c'est vraiment un
super produit très joli bien placé au
niveau tarif je puis vous assurer que
pour fabriquer un produit comme celui là
avec une coque complètement transparente
avec des écouteurs avec un design
transparence a dû leur coûter une petite
fortune à faire et pour autant ils sont
super bien positionnée au tarif de 99
euros la copie est très bien faite elle
est bien maîtrisée sont pas les
meilleurs une fois de plus aux écouteurs
du marché mais ce qu'ils font ils le
font bien donc si vous voulez un produit
assez atypique si vous voulez un produit
qui a une bonne qualité audio qui fait
le taf mais qui fera pas non plus tout
cas une réduction proactive même si
c'est pas la meilleure elle est là
malgré tout elle est là et elle fait le
taff 99 euros ou quelque chose qui est
hyper sympa et surtout est ce qui est
vachement bien c'est le début d'une
histoire ses débuts d'une marque si le
lancement il est évident que nothing va
aller beaucoup plus loin dans les temps
à venir aujourd'hui il commence par des
écouteurs c'est assez connu c'est très
connu parce qu'en fait on n'attend pas
une marque qui commence par des
écouteurs on n'attend pas un karl pays
on attend pas un acquis ce qui arrive
avec des écouteurs et pour autant il
commence comme ça il se structure et
sont en train de structurer la boîte ils
sont en train de mettre en place toutes
les équipes pour venir travailler sur
d'autres produits eco systèmes a kiss
nous l'a dit il ya d'autres produits qui
vont arriver et quand on sait que le
produit aujourd'hui au coeur d'un
écosystème ses smartphones je serais pas
surpris qu'on en voit arriver dans les
temps à venir ça ça reste très
hypothétique mais ça me paraîtrait en
tout cas très logique parce
qu'aujourd'hui et vous regarder
n'importe quelle marque avons regardé
par exemple huawei avec leur stratégie
le smartphone reste au centre chez apple
c'est la même chose chez samsung c'est
la même chose donc je serais pas surpris
qu'on voit arriver dans les temps à
venir je ne sais quand probablement un
smartphone dosing allez savoir en tout
cas moi j'aime bien a vous de me dire
vous ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaire qu'est ce que vous pensez de
ce thé nothing de ces ikhwan est ce que
la marque elle voyait le nom vous en
pensez quoi le film ça vous plaît bien
le nom des écouteurs ikhwan choses assez
marrant pour le coup dis moi avoue bowie
vous surtout vous derrière ce que vous
en pensez bien pas bien ça vous bosse ça
vous plait pas alors les pros
d'aujourd'hui sont sold out mais
vachement devant tu passes ils arrivent
à suivre pour l'instant au niveau de la
fabrication mais ça va arriver donc s'il
vous plaît une fois de plus vous méliand
bada description d'ici la porte et vous
bien des bisous de l'amour il a très tôt